holy dis tu attendais pas mon père vient
d'ouvrir
tu es donc venu pleurer le rav pourquoi
d'autre à part ça partait soudainement
tant de choses ont changé en ton absence
bonjour et si comme on jette tu as un
look très new york avec toi et steve
vous êtes mariés il était toujours tous
les trois mais tu es parti gros steak
nous deux tu es toujours en colère
contre moi tu as disparu
pourquoi tu t'es marié esti j'étais
convaincu que le mariage ne guérirait
autant le faire avec notre meilleur ami
tu n'es pas marié qu'il te faut
quelqu'un c'est tout à fait normal à bon
c'est tout à fait normal ou c'est la
société qui l'imposent je pensais à ta
vie à new york
je suivais le décalage horaire je savais
que tu étais rêverie et quand tu dormais
tu avec moi
rec
monnet
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe dis-le moi on a
toujours été franc l'un envers l'autre
et ce type
elle profite de toi tu avales j'adore
quand on était plus jeunes que d'être
pareil j'ai toujours vous
[Musique]
tu devrais le quitter
je suis né dans cette communauté je
n'avais pas le choix
qu'est ce que tu vas faire qui ne l'est
pas
fier d'avoir fait
[Musique]
je veux que tu me rendes des libertés
il n'y a rien de plus beau
la liberté de choisir
[Musique]